kamui was already a legend during his lifetime as a
successful writer as a
philosopher and also as a
womanizer his philosophical discovery
is still provocative today because like all
great philosophers he asked the question
about the meaning of life
but his answer is completely out of the
ordinary of course the question of meaning has been used since  always
answered very differently for
plato, for example, it is good that
the world holds together at its core for
each the world spirit for marx the work
for nietzsche the will to power and
for habermas the development of language
basically every philosopher gives
his own answer to the  question of meaning
not so he has no
worse nor he gives an answer but
this is extremely sobering
to the question what is the meaning of
life boss the plain and
simple there is no one life is
absurd we always plan ahead in the
end but our whole life depends
from a series of coincidences that we do
not know  being able to
influence there is no real goal either our
task is to continue living proudly and undaunted
to continue
to compare the life of man with
the myth of sisyphus
who tirelessly tries
to push a ball up the mountain although
it keeps rolling down it, but
precisely in this one  doing seemingly senseless and
absurd things is the chance of a
fulfilling life can tells us how we
can live with this absurdity
we have to imagine how it came about
as a happy person
the book came and explained for 60 minutes
based on selected quotes and examples
the theory of  absurdities as they came
to us in his main philosophical work or
in the main works the myth of
sisyphus and man in revolt
presented in the chapter what is the use of us
ka-news discovery today also describes
the absurd lifestyle he recommended
khami's dazzling examples
of the absurd  life designs  and his
suggestions on how
best to confront the absurd and lead a life without god
and politically ideological
orientation are of powerful topicality, especially in modern
societies like ours